>> PREVIOUSLY ON
AMERICAN'S NEXT TOP MODEL
>> THE GIRLS LEARNED
HOW TO STRUT THEIR STUFF
WITH DITA VON TEESE...
>> SHOWING THE FOOT OFF
AND, LIKE, GOING UP YOUR LEG.
>> WHOO!
>> AND FOUND THEMSELVES ON THE
MENU
AT A SEXY CHALLENGE.
THAT LEFT ANCHAL
WORRIED ABOUT HER APPEARANCE.
>> IT'S NOT LIKE
I WANT TO GAIN MORE WEIGHT.
IT'S JUST THAT I STRESS OUT
>> ROMANCE WAS IN THE AIR
AT A PHOTO SHOOT WITH FABIO...
>> I JUST FELL IN LOVE!
>> BUT BROOKE COULDN'T CONQUER
HER INHIBITIONS...
>> RIGHT NOW YOU'RE GOING...
(retches) AND IT'S LIKE
CHUNKSVILLE IN HERE.
>> AND SHE WAS SENT HOME.
SEVEN GIRLS REMAIN.
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
>> ♪ YOU WANT TO BE ON TOP? ♪
♪♪
>> HEY, GUYS,
WE GOT A LETTER FROM BROOKE.
>> IT WAS A HUGE SURPRISE,
BROOKE GOING HOME.
>> EUGENA.
>> NO ONE EXCEPTED IT.
EVERYONE WAS SO SAD.
>> ♪ WE LOVE YOU, BROOKE ♪
♪ AND WE GONNA ♪
♪ MISS YOU LIKE HELL ♪
♪ YOU BROUGHT TO THIS HOUSE ♪
♪ A FEELING I COULD FEEL ♪
I SAW AN IMPROVEMENT IN HER
BIGGER THAN ANYONE ELSE.
>> IT JUST SUCKS BECAUSE,
YOU KNOW, SO MANY PEOPLE
DON'T APPRECIATE THIS.
>> I COULD GO FROM
8:00 IN THE MORNING
TILL 8:00 AT NIGHT
FOR TEN YEARS DOING THIS,
AND BE HAPPY WITH IT.
>> WITH ME,
IT'S THE EXACT OPPOSITE
OF EVERYBODY.
THIS WAS NEVER MY DREAM.
I HAVE THE TALENT TO BE A MODEL.
I JUST DON'T KNOW IF I HAVE
EVERYTHING THAT IT TAKES--
LIKE, YOU KNOW,
THE--THE FASHION KNOWLEDGE,
WHICH I KNOW I DON'T HAVE.
I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT I'M DOING,
AND I...
I'M NOT HAVING--
I'M NOT FIGURING IT OUT.
>> I WANT THIS.
I WANT TO WIN THIS.
I WANT TO DO BIG THINGS
WITH MY LIFE,
AND I'M SEEING PEOPLE STAY
WEEK AFTER WEEK
WHO DON'T EVEN WANT IT.
>> TYRA MAIL!
"IF YOU COULD BUMP ONE GIRL
OUT OF THE COMPETITION,
WHO WOULD IT BE?
LOVE, TYRA."
>> WHY Y'ALL LOOKING AT ME
THAT WAY?
(laughter)
♪♪
>> HI, YOU GUYS.
>> HI!
>> I'M GABBY REECE,
AND I'M HERE TO TALK TO YOU
ABOUT ACTION MODELING.
>> I WAS ACTUALLY
REALLY, REALLY EXCITED
TO SEE GABRIELLE REECE,
'CAUSE I ALWAYS THOUGHT
THAT YOU--YOU COULDN'T
BE ATHLETIC AND MODEL,
AND SHE'S THE PERFECT EXAMPLE
OF DOING BOTH.
>> I USED TO MODEL,
AND THEN I PLAYED
PROFESSIONAL BEACH VOLLEYBALL
AFTER THAT,
AND I ALWAYS WAS DOING MODELING
THAT HAD A LOT OF ACTION IN IT.
>> I PLAY VOLLEYBALL IN COLLEGE,
AND SO SEEING GABRIELLE,
I WAS JUST SO EXCITED.
IT KIND OF GAVE ME
A BETTER ATTITUDE
ABOUT THIS WHOLE COMPETITION.
>> FIRST OFF,
WE'RE GONNA TEACH YOU
HOW TO DIVE FOR A VOLLEYBALL
ON A MARK,
MAKE IT LOOK REAL
BUT THEN SOMEHOW REMEMBERING
TO STILL LOOK GOOD TO CAMERA.
AND NOW YOU GUYS
ARE GONNA GO OVER THERE
AND CHANGE INTO YOUR BIKINIS,
AND WE'LL GET STARTED
AND HAVE A LOT OF FUN.
(laughter)
♪♪
>> MY FAT'S GONNA
JIGGLE EVERYWHERE.
I'M NOT A VERY SPORTSY PERSON.
MY BODY ISN'T
IN GOOD SHAPE RIGHT NOW.
I DON'T NEED TO BE IN A BIKINI
DOING ACTION MOVES,
SO I WASN'T VERY HAPPY.
I LOOK GROSS.
I DON'T WANNA BE HERE.
>> ANCHAL DOESN'T LIKE
WEARING A BIKINI
BECAUSE SHE'S GOT
A LITTLE BIT EXTRA WEIGHT
ON HER THAT, AS A MODEL,
I DON'T THINK SHE CAN HAVE.
>> NOW HERE'S THE DEAL.
THINK ABOUT--
THERE'S A CAMERA RIGHT HERE
THAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO GET UNDERNEATH THE BALL,
MAKE IT LOOK REAL.
AND ALL YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE TO DO IS WATCH...
AND ALL YOU HAVE TO DO
IS DIVE UP AND GET IT, RIGHT?
OKAY, CARIDEE, GO FIRST.
I'M HERE TODAY
TO TEACH ACTION MODELING,
'CAUSE IT'S HARD TO CATCH
AN ACTION SHOT SOMETIMES.
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
TO BRING THOSE EMOTIONS
UP TO THE EYES.
IT DOESN'T MATTER IF THEY'RE
DOING ACTION MODELING
OR COUTURE, ANYTHING.
OKAY, HERE WE GO.
♪♪
>> OH, MY GOODNESS.
YOU DON'T WANT TO HAVE
SOME FACIAL EXPRESSION THAT'S...
SO GRITTY THAT
THEY WOULDN'T REALLY USE IT.
>> I FEEL LIKE THAT WAS
REALLY GOOFY AND AWKWARD.
HOPEFULLY, IF THERE WAS
A PHOTOGRAPHER THERE,
THEY WOULD'VE GOT A GOOD SHOT.
>> HERE WE GO.
GOOD TRY.
THAT'S GOOD. THAT'S OKAY.
OKAY, NEXT ONE.
>> I PLAYED VOLLEYBALL,
LIKE, IN TENTH GRADE,
AND I SAT ON THE BENCH.
IT SUCKS.
>> HERE WE GO.
GO, GO.
GOOD TRY.
>> JAEDA, DO IT UP.
>> GO, JAEDA!
>> IT WAS REALLY NICE
TO ACTUALLY DO SOMETHING
I KNOW HOW TO DO...
>> GO AHEAD.
>> AND IT--HAVE TO RELATE
TO MODELING.
>> EXCELLENT.
LET'S GIVE HER A HAND.
THAT WAS SO GOOD.
OKAY, NEXT ONE.
AMANDA, LOOK EXCITED.
JUST REACT TO IT.
>> VOLLEYBALL KINDA SUCKS.
>> OHH.
>> I LOOK STUPID.
>> WELL, I ALSO WANNA BE ABLE
TO SEE YOUR FACE.
OKAY, WHO'S NEXT?
OKAY, MICHELLE'S GONNA GO.
>> I ACTUALLY AM NERVOUS,
BASICALLY BECAUSE I LOOK LIKE
I'M ABOUT TO BREAK
A LOT OF THE TIME,
WHICH ISN'T GOOD.
>> HERE WE GO.
OOPS. OOH!
>> (laughs)
>> ARE YOU OKAY?
SEE, IT DOESN'T MATTER,
BECAUSE IF THE CAMERA GUY'S
RIGHT HERE,
IT'LL LOOK THE SAME
AS IF THE BALL WENT PERFECT.
OKAY, NEXT ONE.
>> HELL NO.
>> ANCHAL,OKAY, IF WE WERE
SHOOTING,
WE'D HAVE TO BE
TOTALLY IN OUR GEAR.
ANCHAL DIDN'T EVEN WANT TO COME
OUT
IN HER BATHING SUIT.
SHE SEEMS A LITTLE BIT SHY.
>> ANCHAL, YOU'RE A MODEL.
YOU HAVE TO BE READY
TO BE STRIPPED DOWN AT ANY TIME
WHEN YOU'RE A MODEL.
>> HERE WE GO.
OKAY, GOOD.
>> WHOO!
>> LOOK A LITTLE MORE INTENSE.
>> OKAY.
>> OKAY? HERE YOU GO. GO GET IT,
GO GET IT! GOOD TRY.
SO I THINK IT'S JUST A QUESTION
OF HER GETTING COMFORTABLE
KNOWING THAT SHE CAN DO IT.
SO WE WORKED ON
SOME OF THE IMPORTANT THINGS
FOR ACTION MODELING,
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
SPENDING THE DAY WITH ME,
AND--AND I WANT TO
WISH YOU ALL GOOD LUCK.
>> THANK YOU!
>> OKAY. BYE, YOU GUYS.
>> BYE!
>> TAKE CARE.
>> ANCHAL IS ALWAYS
SELF-CONSCIOUS.
IT MAKES HER LOOK EVEN--
I GUESS--MORE FLABBY
AND MORE LIKE A BIG OLD BLOB,
THE WAY SHE CARRIES HERSELF,
BECAUSE SHE DOESN'T
CARRY HERSELF LIKE
SHE'S PROUD OF WHAT SHE HAS.
♪♪
>> THERE'S TWO SIDES TO ANCHAL,
AND ONE IS SEXY AND CONFIDENT,
AND ONE IS, LIKE, TIMID AND SHY.
>> SHE JUST DOESN'T HAVE THE CONFIDENCE AT ALL.
>> THIS ISN'T ABOUT JUST HAVING
A REALLY GORGEOUS FACE.
>> YEAH.
>> I JUST DON'T GET IT.
I'M SO FRUSTRATED!
I'M FRUSTRATED WITH HER
ATTITUDE.
PICTURES.
I'M JUST LIKE, I JUST WISH
YOU WOULD GO HOME ALREADY,
BECAUSE I'VE SEEN
A LOT OF PHOTOS OF YOU
WHERE IT'S LIKE...
>> BEING IN THE HOUSE,
I DO FEEL LIKE
I HAVE NO FRIENDS.
I'M NOT NICE TO MELROSE BECAUSE
I'VE TRIEDBEING NICE TO HER.
TRYING TO GET ALONG WITH HER
DOESN'T WORK.
SHE DOES BITCHY LITTLE THINGS,
AND IT MAKES YOU
WANT TO SLAP THE HO.
>> TYRA MAIL!
>> "ARE YOU GOING TO SNAP
WHEN THE PRESSURE IS ON?
LOVE, TYRA."
>> "LOVE, TYRA."
SNAP?
♪♪
>> WE'RE IN
THE MIDDLE OF NOWHERE.
DON'T REALLY HAVE ANY IDEA
WHAT WE COULD BE DOING.
>> IT WAS SO FREAKING HOT.
AND THEN THERE'S, LIKE,
THIS RACETRACK.
(brakes screeching)
(engine revving)
>> WELL, WE WALKED DOWN THIS
RACETRACK,
AND WE SEE THIS CRAZY GUY.
(brakes screeching)
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> HE LOOKS LIKE
A GOTHIC DRAG QUEEN.
>> I'M JAMES ST. JAMES,
AUTHOR, BON VIVANT
AND NASCAR ENTHUSIAST.
>> JAMES ST. JAMES
IS A VERY BUBBLY CHARACTER.
I'VE SEEN HIM ON PAST SEASONS,
AND HE'S JUST REALLY OUT THERE.
>> I'M HERE TO JUDGE THE GIRLS.
YESTERDAY, THEY'D LEARNED, UM,
SOME ACTION PHOTOGRAPHY,
AND TODAY I'M HERE
TO HELP THEM INCORPORATE THAT
INTO, UH, THE CHALLENGE TODAY.
I'M HERE WITH STANTON BARRETT,
THE HUMP MUFFIN OF RACING.
>> I'M STANTON BARRETT,
NASCAR DRIVE AND TEAM OWNER.
I'VE ALSO BEEN INVOLVED
IN FASHION, RECENTLY SHOOTING
WITH
WALTER CHIN AND "L'UOMO VOGUE."
>> I SAW THAT.
THAT WAS FANTASTIC.
>> SO WE'RE HERE TODAY
TO SHOOT ACTION SHOTS.
YOU GUYS LEARNED ABOUT THAT
YESTERDAY, AND WE'RE GONNA
INCORPORATE IT IN YOUR SHOOTING
TODAY.
>> NOW A LOT OF TIMES,
WHAT HAPPENS IS YOU'LL BE
ARGUING WITH YOUR BOYFRIEND
OVER WHOSE CAREER
IS MORE IMPORTANT.
STANTON BARRETT
IS GOING TO BE YOUR BOYFRIEND,
AND YOU'RE GOING
TO BE ANGRY WITH HIM.
YOU'RE GOING TO BE LEAPING
AND JUMPING.
>> DURING THIS, YOU'RE GONNA
SHOOT YOUR OWN SHOTS TODAY
WITH THIS REMOTE CONTROL.
>> I WANT YOU
TO CLICK ON THE BUTTON
AND FACE THE CAMERA AS YOU DO.
YOU HAVE TEN MINUTES
TO GET DRESSED.
NOW GO!
>> (screaming)
♪♪
>> WHOO!
>> THE CHALLENGE
IS TO INCORPORATE ACTION
INTO THE PHOTOGRAPHY.
EUGENA, HAVE YOU EVER
HAD A BOYFRIEND THAT YOU GET MAD
AT?
>> YES, I HAVE.
>> DOES HE HAVE A CAREER THAT'S
MORE IMPORTANT THAN YOURS?
>> NO, HE DOESN'T.
>> OKAY. ON YOUR MARK, GET SET, GO.
OH! THAT WAS GOOD.
>> THIS CHALLENGE
IS PRETTY DIFFICULT BECAUSE
YOU HAVE TO BE IN MIDAIR
WHILE YOU'RE TRYING TO LOOK
MAD AND ANGRY.
>> GO!
YES!
>> STANTON WAS JUST
THE PUNCHING BAG.
>> MY CAREER IS MORE IMPORTANT
THAN YOURS.
>> NO, IT'S NOT!
>> GO!
ATTACK!
>> AAH!
>> OH, YEAH!
GO! YES!
I WANT POW! GO!
YES!
>> WHOO!
>> OH, THAT WAS IT.
>> THAT WAS AWESOME!
>> GO! YES!
>> YEAH!
>> AND, GO!
THAT WAS GOOD. VERY GOOD.
OKAY, CARIDEE.
>> THIS IS
YOUR LAST RACE, BITCH.
>> UH-OH, HERE WE GO.
>> FINAL LAP.
>> ATTACK!
>> (laughs)
YOUR LAST LAP!
>> THAT WAS HOT.
>> AAH!
I LOVE YOU.
WE'LL HAVE MAKE-UP SEX LATER.
>> (laughs)
>> (laughs) JOKING.
>> OKAY, OUR NEXT GIRL, ANCHAL.
OKAY, LET'S BRING OUT
YOUR BOYFRIEND.
>> ANCHAL'S, LIKE,
TOO PRETTY FOR THIS SHOT.
>> USE YOUR PASSION,
USE YOUR ANGER AND DRAMA, OKAY?
AND, GO! ACTION!
>> WHEN IT GETS TO MY TURN,
I'M SO NERVOUS THAT I'M LIKE,
OH, MAN, I DON'T WANNA DO THIS.
>> WHAT'S THE MATTER?
>> I'M SO AFRAID, LIKE, I'M GONNA KILL HIM.
>> DON'T BE AFRAID OF HIM.
HE'S TOUGHER THAN HE LOOKS.
>> I CAN HANDLE IT.
>> LOOK AT THE CAMERA.
GET MAD AT HIM.
ATTACK HIM NOW!
>> I'M SO AFRAID
OF MY BOOBS FALLING OUT,
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
>> I DON'T CARE
ABOUT YOUR BOOBS.
>> SHUT UP AND GO.
HOW MANY TIMES HAVE WE SEEN
YOUR BOOBS, ANCHAL? COME ON.
>> BUTTERSHOT.
>> GO, NOW! JUMP, LEAP.
>> WAIT.
>> (grunts)
>> HOW MANY SHOTS IS THAT?
>> I'M NOT AN ANGRY PERSON.
>> YOU HAVE TO BE ANGRY.
IT'S YOUR CAREER.
HOW BAD DO YOU WANT THIS?
>> ANCHAL DOESN'T EVEN SHOW THAT SHE'S TRYING,
AND IT'S FRUSTRATING.
>> NEXT GIRL IS MICHELLE.
COME ON OUT.
HERE WE GO WITH THE LAST ONE.
>> FINALLY WE GOT TO DO
SOMETHING
WHERE IT'S JUST PICTURES,
THE THING I'M GOOD AT,
JUMPING AND ACTION,
AND I LOVE SPORTS AND ACTION
SO IT WAS MY THING.
TWO, THREE.
>> I'M SORRY
FOR RUINING YOUR CAR.
I'M REALLY NOT TRYING TO.
(crunch)
>> (laughs) OH!
>> OH!
>> I'M SORRY.
>> WHERE DO YOU WANT ME TO GO?
>> DID YOU JUST BREAK HIS CAR?
>> SCREWUP, MICHELLE.
>> LET ME SEE.
>> (chuckles) I'M SORRY.
>> STOP!
>> NOW AS YOU KNOW,
THAT WAS A VERY DIFFICULT SHOOT,
I THINK, BUT YOU ALL DID
A REALLY FANTASTIC JOB.
>> IT WAS DEFINITELY A TOUGH
CHOICE.
>> OUR--OUR WINNER WAS-- WHO WAS OUR WINNER?
IT WAS MICHELLE, RIGHT?
COME ON, GO,
COME OVER HERE, GIRL.
GIVE US A HUG!
>> SORRY IF I HURT YOU.
>> MICHELLE WINS
THE CHALLENGE TODAY,
AND IT'S REALLY EXCITING
'CAUSE MICHELLE'S NEVER WON,
SO I'M GLAD IT WENT TO SOMEONE
THAT WASN'T EUGENA OR MELROSE.
>> SO YOU GET TO PICK
THREE FRIENDS TO PARTICIPATE
IN WHAT YOU GET FOR YOUR REWARD.
>> UH, CARIDEE.
>> HEY!
>> THERE YOU GO. THERE'S ONE.
>> AMANDA AND MELROSE.
>> YAY!
>> YAY! OKAY.
>> I'M SURPRISED JUST BECAUSE
NOBODY'S GETTING ALONG WITH
MELROSE,
NOBODY LIKES HER AS A FRIEND.
WE JUST KINDA KNOW
WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH HER.
>> HUH?
>> NOW WHAT YOU GIRLS
HAVE WON IS,
YOU HAVE WON THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR A $10,000 SHOPPING SPREE.
>> (screams)
>> WHAT?!
(laughter and cheering)
>> OKAY, GOOD-BYE, EVERYONE!
>> BYE!
>> THANKS, YOU GUYS.
>> THANK YOU, JAMES!
>> OF COURSE I'M SAD THAT
I CAN'T GET TO SHARE
IN THE REWARD.
I'M THE ONLY GIRL
WHO HASN'T BEEN CHOSEN
FOR ANY OF THE THINGS.
♪♪
>> OH, HEY, YOU AGAIN!
>> HI.
>> WELCOME, GIRLS.
>> HI, YOU'RE HERE IN OUR
FASHION SHOWROOM.
WE PRODUCE ALL SORTS OF EVENTS,
NONE BIGGER THAN OUR BILLION
DOLLAR BABES
SAMPLE SALES.
WE'VE GOT OVER $10,000 WORTH
OF HANDBAGS, JEWELRY
AND GREAT CLOTHING FOR YOUR
COMPETITION TODAY,
SO HAVE FUN.
>> BECAUSE YOU LEARNED ABOUT
ACTION TODAY,
WE'RE GONNA DO A SHOPPING SPREE.
MICHELLE, YOU'RE THE WINNER,
AND YOUR THREE FRIENDS YOU
PICKED--
AMANDA, MELROSE AND CARIDEE--
YOU HAVE 30 SECONDS
FROM THAT LINE
TO GO TO THE SHOWROOM,
PUT ON AS MANY CLOTHES
AS YOU CAN.
IF YOU'RE NOT BACK HERE
WITHIN 30 SECONDS,
YOU'RE DISQUALIFIED.
IF YOU MAKE IT BACK IN 30
SECONDS,
THE PERSON WITH THE MOST CLOTHES
WINS EVERYBODY'S CLOTHES.
>> (gasps) WHAT?
>> YOU GOT THAT?
>> OKAY. COOL.
>> ARE YOU READY?
>> I HOPE IT'S NOT ALL DRESSES.
>> GO!
>> AAH!
♪♪
>> HURRY UP, YOU GUYS!
>> DON'T FORGET
TO LOAD UP, LADIES!
>> IT'S REALLY FRUSTRATING
TO WATCH PEOPLE SHOP.
I WAS JUST LIKE,
WHY THE HELL ARE WE HERE?
CAN'T WE SIT IN THE LIMO?
COULDN'T WE GO HOME?
I MEAN, WE HAVE TO STAND HERE
AND WATCH?
>> NINE...
>> HURRY UP!
>> EIGHT, SEVEN, SIX...
>> OW!
>> FIVE, FOUR,
THREE, TWO,
ONE! OH!
>> I CAN'T FIND MY HAND.
(laughter)
>> LADIES, YOU'VE DONE
EXCEPTIONALLY WELL.
I'M IMPRESSED,
I'LL TELL YOU WHAT. I'VE SEEN
SOME SAMPLE SALE SHOPPING,
BUT THIS TAKES THE CAKE.
WE HAVE TO NOW COUNT YOUR ITEMS
TO IDENTIFY THE WINNER.
WE HAVE TWO HANDBAGS,
THREE ITEMS, FOUR, FIVE, SIX,
SEVEN ITEMS. WELL DONE.
ONE PAIR OF TROUSERS.
>> I LIKE THOSE.
THOSE ARE MY FAVORITE.
>> TWO, THREE, FOUR...
THREE JESSICA ELLIOT NECKLACES,
THAT WOULD MAKE SEVEN...
EIGHT, NINE, TEN
AND ONE MORE PAIR--11.
WELL DONE.
ONE, TWO, THREE...
>> (speaking indistinctly)
>> FOUR, FIVE, SIX, SEVEN,
EIGHT, NINE, TEN.
SO FAR, WE HAVE
MICHELLE IN THE LEAD WITH 11.
ONE, TWO, THREE,
FOUR, FIVE, SIX,
(chuckles) SEVEN...
EIGHT, NINE, TEN...
>> AAH!
>> 11, 12...
>> NUMBER 13.
>> 13, IN THAT ORDER.
>> AAH, THANK YOU SO MUCH!
>> WHAT HAPPENS NOW, STANTON?
>> YEAH, WHAT HAPPENS?
>> UNFORTUNATELY,
EVERYBODY HAS TO GIVE MELROSE
THEIR CLOTHES.
>> I DIDN'T KNOW
THERE WAS A CHALLENGE
WITHIN MY CHALLENGE PRIZE,
SO I GET NOTHING UNLESS
MELROSE GIVES ME SOMETHING,
SO THAT KIND OF SUCKS.
>> (laughs)
>> BUT YOU HAVE TO CARRY IT.
>> IT'S LIKE A DREAM!
>> WE WERE IN THE BACK LAUGHING
BECAUSE MELROSE
GRABS EVERYTHING,
BECAUSE SHE UNDERSTOOD THE RULES
BUT THE OTHER GIRLS DIDN'T.
>> BYE!
>> SEE YA.
>> SEE YOU LATER.
>> IT FEELS REALLY GOOD TO GET
THE CLOTHES,
BUT I FEEL LIKE EVERY GIRL
IS WANTING TO KILL ME RIGHT NOW.
♪♪
>> I'M CLOSER TO MY SISTER,
AND I'M CLOSER TO CARIDEE,
AND ANCHAL AND ME JUST HAVE
A LOVE/HATE RELATIONSHIP.
>> AT THE HOUSE,
THE GIRLS WERE TALKING ABOUT
WHO WE LIKED IN THE BEGINNING,
WHO WE DIDN'T LIKE
IN THE BEGINNING.
I DO FEEL LIKE I HAVE NO FRIENDS
HERE.
>> YOU ACT LIKE YOU'RE A CHILD.
>> YOU DON'T EVEN KNOW ME
TO SAY THAT.
>> ANCHAL, YOU HAVE NO RESPECT
FOR OTHER PEOPLE'S SPACE.
YOU HAVE WALKED INTO ME
TEN TIMES IN THIS HOUSE
AND NOT EVEN THOUGHT TWICE ABOUT
IT.
>> I CAN'T TALK TO THESE GIRLS.
I JUST WANT TO GET AWAY FROM IT.
IT'S AFFECTING ME,
WHICH IS BAD BECAUSE
I DON'T WANT IT TO AFFECT ME.
♪♪
>> TYRA MAIL!
"TOMORROW, YOU WILL DEFY
THE BIGGEST MODEL STEREOTYPE.
DON'T BE AN AIRHEAD!"
>> YAY.
>> "LOVE, TYRA."
>> I DON'T KNOW,
IT'S GONNA BE SOMETHING ABOUT
MODELS BEING STUPID.
>> I DON'T GET IT.
(laughter)
♪♪
>> SO WE PULL UP TO THIS
AIRPORT,
AND SO WE'RE THINKING,
WHAT'S GOING ON?
>> I'M LIKE, OH, MY GOSH,
WE'RE GOING SKYDIVING.
>> (cheering)
>> HEY!
IT'S ABOUT BEING
IN FLIGHT TODAY, BABY.
>> YES!
>> WHAT HAVE YOU GUYS
BEEN LEARNING ABOUT THIS WEEK?
>> ACTION!
>> SO WE GOT
AN EXPERT ACTION PHOTOGRAPHER
HERE TO SHOOT YOU GIRLS.
PATRIK, COME ON OUT HERE.
>> HI, PATRIK!
>> HEY, HEY, HEY!
>> SO THIS IS PATRIK,
AND THE REAL EXCITING PART IS,
TODAY IS YOUR VERY FIRST
COVERGIRL ASSIGNMENT.
>> OH, YAY!
>> WOW.
>> COVERGIRL IS ADDING
A NEW FOUNDATION
TO THEIR TruBlend FAMILY,
AND IT'S CALLED
TruBlend WHIPPED FOUNDATION,
WHICH IS ALL ABOUT BEING
LIGHT AND WEIGHTLESS
SO YOU ALMOST DON'T
FEEL IT ON YOUR SKIN.
WE'RE GONNA MAKE YOU GIRLS
SEXY SPACE SIRENS,
IF THERE IS SUCH A THING.
NOW WE'RE NOT GONNA
GO UP 14,000 FEET
AND THROW YOU OUT OF A PLANE.
>> (laughs)
>> I'M JUST RELIEVED,
BECAUSE I'M NOT TOO COOL WITH THAT,
JUMPING OUT OF A PLANE.
I'M NOT TRYING TO GET HURT.
>> BUT WE ARE
PUTTING YOU IN THE AIR.
THAT'S A TRAINING FACILITY
FOR SKYDIVERS,
AND WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO
IS PUT YOU OVER A HUGE FAN
THAT MAKES YOU AIRBORNE.
SO LET'S GO. LET'S HAVE FUN.
LET'S GET AIRBORNE.
>> WHOO!
>> OKAY.
>> WOW.
>> INDOOR SKYDIVING LESSONS
IS ONE OF MY THINGS
THAT I'VE ALWAYS WANTED TO DO.
IT'S SUPER EXCITING.
(alarm buzzes)
♪♪
>> YOU HAVE A COUPLE
OF INSTRUCTORS TO HELP YOU.
THIS IS SHANE.
>> FLYING IS REALLY EASY.
THE KEY TO THAT IS STAYING SLOW
AND STAYING IN CONTROL.
>> AND REMEMBER,
THIS IS GONNA BE
A COMPOSITE PICTURE.
WE'RE GONNA PUT YOU IN SPACE
WITH COVERGIRL FOUNDATION.
LET'S GO TO HAIR AND MAKEUP.
♪♪
>> THIS IS VERY NATURAL.
IT'S BEAUTIFUL.
>> DOESN'T EVEN FEEL LIKE
I'M WEARING ANYTHING.
>> YOU READY TO DO THIS?
GIVE ME FIVE.
TEN.
(alarm buzzing)
>> THE INSTRUCTORS ARE
PRETTY MUCH HOLDING YOU THE WHOLE TIME,
SO WHEN--ONCE YOU REACH OUT
AND, LIKE, MESS UP YOUR BALANCE,
YOU JUST FLIP EVERYWHERE.
IT'S SO HARD TO, LIKE,
STAY BALANCED.
>> MICHELLE'S BODY LANGUAGE
WAS PRETTY GOOD.
PROBLEM IS, MICHELLE LACKED
A LOT OF GRACE...
UM, NO.
AND HER HANDS LOOKED LIKE
CATCHER'S MITTS.
NOW WHAT WAS THE PROBLEM
WITH YOU FLIPPING OVER?
>> (laughs) I DON'T KNOW.
>> THANKS, MICHELLE.
>> I DON'T THINK
I DID THAT GREAT BECAUSE
THAT WAS A LITTLE HARDER
THAN I THOUGHT IT WOULD BE.
IT'S--IT'S HARD TO CONTROL.
>> I'M FEELING PRETTY CONFIDENT
ABOUT THE SHOOT.
>> YOU LOOK CUTE.
>> I DO THINK I HAVE
A COVERGIRL FACE.
I HAVE A COVERGIRL ATTITUDE.
(alarm buzzing)
>> I STEPPED INTO THIS
CHAMBER-LIKE THING.
THE WIND IS BLOWING UPWARD,
AND YOU'RE JUST--
YOUR WHOLE FACE
IS, LIKE, FLAPPING.
I REALLY HAD TO FOCUS ON
KEEPING MY BODY REALLY RELAXED,
INCLUDING MY FACE.
>> JAEDA, IN GENERAL, IS NOT
THE MOST GRACEFUL GIRL ON SET.
BUT TODAY, THIS SHOOT
MIGHT JUST SAVE JAEDA.
SHE JUST LOOKED SUPER GRACEFUL.
WERE YOU NERVOUS
WHEN YOU WENT UP?
>> NO, I WAS LIKE,
"OOH, GO HIGHER!"
(laughter)
>> THIS WEEK'S BEEN ALL ABOUT
ACTION, ACTION, ACTION MODELING.
♪♪
>> I'M DOING KINDA
NOT SO GOOD AT FIRST.
I WAS HAVING A HARD TIME
GETTING USED TO IT.
IT--IT REALLY IS A LOT OF WORK.
>> AMANDA--SHE WAS, LIKE,
FLAILING AROUND LIKE A RAG DOLL.
I FELT BAD.
>> IT WAS CRAZY,
BUT IT WAS SO MUCH FUN.
>> OH, TWIN.
>> OH, I LOVE THIS!
THE THING I LOVED ABOUT AMANDA
IS SHE PUT HER ARM UP AND THEN
SHE REACHED HER OTHER HAND
DOWN TO HER CHEST,
AND IT LOOKED SO GRACEFUL,
LIKE A-A BALLERINA IN THE SKY.
THAT WAS GREAT!
YOU'RE THE ONLY GIRL
WHO WENT AND PUT THEIR HAND
ON HER CHEST.
GOOD JOB.
>> ANCHAL, THIS LOOKS
REALLY GREAT ON YOU.
>> FRICKIN' AWESOME.
>> IT'S JUST KIND OF LIGHTWEIGHT.
>> YEAH, IT FEELS SUPER LIGHT.
I CAN BARELY FEEL IT.
>> SUCK IT IN.
>> I AM SUCKING IT IN.
>> WELL, SUCK IT IN HARDER.
>> (scoffs)
>> GIRL, SHE GONNA BE FLOATING.
SHE AIN'T SUCKING NOTHING.
LET'S GO.
>> SUCK IT IN.
>> I HOPE I GET
SOME GOOD PICTURES.
I'M KIND OF NERVOUS.
I JUST SAW AMANDA GO,
AND I WAS LIKE, OH, CRAP.
>> (laughs)
>> WHEN I WAS FLIPPING AROUND,
I SAW THEM LOOKING.
I'M LIKE, WHY ARE YOU GUYS HERE?
STOP! DON'T LOOK AT ME.
>> ANCHAL DIDN'T COME OFF
GRACEFUL...
AS IF THAT'S ANYTHING NEW.
>> EUGENA, YOU WANNA GO FROM
THIS MOVE TO THIS MOVE.
YOU GOTTA DO IT LIKE THIS.
THIS...
TO THAT.
>> OKAY.
>> THIS PHOTO SHOOT
WAS PRETTY IMPORTANT,
'CAUSE THEY'VE BEEN TELLING ME
OVER AND OVER AGAIN THAT
I HAVE NO FACE IN MY PICTURES.
SO MY MAIN FOCUS
WAS TO HAVE A NICE FACE
THROUGH THE GOGGLES
AND THE BIG HELMET
AND ALL THE WIND AND EVERYTHING LIKE THAT.
(alarm ringing)
>> MELROSE, YOU ALWAYS GIVE US
AN AMAZING SHOT.
MAKE THE GIRLS
HATE YOU EVEN MORE!
>> I DON'T KNOW
IF THAT'S POSSIBLE!
>> OH, OKAY.
>> I THINK BECAUSE
I'M DOING WELL HERE THAT
I'M INTIMIDATING OTHER GIRLS.
>> MELROSE IS
MY BIGGEST COMPETITION.
YOU KNOW, SHE TRIES
JUST AS HARD AS I DO.
>> I WANT TO SAY MELROSE
WAS GREAT,
BUT MELROSE WAS PRETTY FLAT.
MELROSE'S FACE
READ COMPLETELY BLANK.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT WENT WRONG.
>> (laughs) UGH.
>> IT WAS HARDER
THAN YOU THOUGHT.
>> YEAH.
>> YOU LOST IT. YOU WENT,
"OH, MY GOD, I'M TURNING..."
>> RIGHT.
>> INSTEAD OF,
"OH, THERE'S THE PRODUCT.
THERE'S THE PRODUCT.
THERE'S THE PRODUCT."
SEE WHAT I'M SAYING?
>> I'M NOT HAPPY. IT WAS
ALMOST LIKE I WANTED TO JUMP
BACK IN THERE AND DO IT AGAIN.
>> MELROSE WASN'T THE BEST.
OOH, THANK GOD!
I WAS LIKE, "FINALLY!"
>> ARE YOU READY?
>> OH, YEAH.
THIS IS SERIOUSLY, LIKE,
THE COOLEST THING
I HAVE EVER DONE.
IT FEELS REALLY COOL
TO BE IN THIS TUNNEL.
I WAS A LITTLE APPREHENSIVE
AT FIRST,
'CAUSE I GET MOTION SICKNESS
REALLY EASILY.
BUT IT WASN'T
ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
YOU JUST FEEL SO FREE AND LIGHT.
>> SHE'S DOING THIS.
>> AAH!
WHOO!
OOH!
>> CARIDEE WAS JUST
ALL OVER THE PLACE,
FLIPPING BACKWARDS AND FORWARDS.
SHE DID NOT LISTEN
TO ME OR THE INSTRUCTORS.
WE TOLD ALL THE GIRLS
TO MAKE ALL THEIR MOVEMENTS
REALLY SLOW.
BUT TO CARIDEE'S CREDIT, THOUGH,
WHEN THINGS STARTED GOING
LITERALLY BELLY-UP,
SHE KEPT REACHING
FOR THAT COVERGIRL FOUNDATION.
>> I WAS REALLY TWISTING
AND TURNING, GIVING THOSE GUYS
WHO WERE HOLDING ME A RIDE.
THEY WERE REALLY TIRED
AFTERWARDS.
>> TYRA MAIL!
>> "TOMORROW YOU WILL MEET
WITH THE JUDGES.
ONLY SIX WILL CONTINUE ON
IN THE HOPES OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
LOVE, TYRA."
>> SIX.
>> I THINK WITH ELIMINATION
THAT IT'S GONNA BE A HARD PANEL.
(German accent) WE DO NOT WANT
TO GO TO PANEL TOMORROW,
BUT I THINK OUR PICTURES
ARE GOING TO BE VERY BEAUTIFUL.
(normal voice) I FEEL LIKE
I PROBABLY GOT
A GOOD PHOTO OUT OF IT.
BUT SINCE THERE WASN'T
ANY POSITIVE FEEDBACK,
I'M NOT GONNA WALK INTO PANEL
AS CONFIDENT AS I HAVE BEFORE.
(German accent) I DO NOT
WANT TO GO.
>> MELROSE SHOULD GO HOME.
SHE'S THE MOST
FREAKIN' ANNOYING PERSON
I HAVE EVER MET.
>> I DON'T KNOW
WHO'S GONNA LEAVE.
>> I'M TIRED OF PEOPLE LEAVING.
IT'S MAKING ME DEPRESSED.
>> I SWEAR, IF THERE'S
A JACKED-UP PICTURE
THAT SHOWS UP ON THERE,
I'M JUST GONNA BE LIKE, "SEND ME HOME."
♪♪
>> HELLO, LADIES.
WELCOME TO THE JUDGING ROOM AGAIN.
YOU HAD A REALLY SERIOUS WEEK,
DIDN'T YOU?
>> OH, YEAH.
>> A LOT OF MOVEMENT
AND A LOT OF ACTION.
SO LET'S GET THE ACTION GOING
RIGHT NOW.
YOU KNOW THE JUDGES.
THE FIRST IS
NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER
NIGEL BARKER...
>> HI, GIRLS.
>> YOUR RUNWAY DIVA,
MISS J. ALEXANDER....
AND FASHION ICON
AND LIVING LEGEND,
THE GORGEOUS TWIGGY.
>> HELLO, GIRLS.
>> HI!
>> (chuckles)
>> AND A WOMAN THAT
I KNOW AND RESPECT
AND HAVE MODELED FOR, ACTUALLY,
BACK IN THE DAY.
WE AIN'T GONNA SAY HOW LONG,
ARE WE?
>> (chuckles) I KNOW.
>> MISS GABRIELLE REECE,
PRO ATHLETE AND MODEL.
I'M SO HAPPY YOU'RE HERE.
>> ME, TOO.
>> YOU GUYS KNOW ABOUT THE FABULOUS PRIZES.
THE FIRST IS A CONTRACT
WITH ONE OF THE TOP
MODELING AGENCIES IN THE WORLD--
ELITE MODEL MANAGEMENT...
A SPREAD AND A COVER
OF "SEVENTEEN" MAGAZINE...
A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVERGIRL COSMETICS.
ALL RIGHT, SO NOW IT'S TIME
FOR YOUR INDIVIDUAL EVALUATIONS,
AND AFTER THAT,
THE JUDGES WILL DELIBERATE
AND DETERMINE WHICH ONE OF YOU
WILL BE ELIMINATED.
EUGENA.
>> HI!
>> YOU'RE FIRST TODAY!
>> (chuckles)
>> ALL RIGHT, EUGENA,
SO THIS WEEK YOU LEARNED
ALL ABOUT MODELING AND ACTION.
SO FOR YOUR JUDGING TEST TODAY,
WE'RE GOING TO TEST THAT.
THE BOYS HERE ARE GONNA CHOOSE
A VERB AND AN ADVERB, AND THEN
HAVE TO ACT THAT OUT.
SO YOU HAVE TO...
>> "SHAKE."
>> "FLIRTATIOUSLY."
YOU COULDN'T GET
A BETTER COMBINATION, HONEY.
(laughter)
>> WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
>> IT LOOKED FRIGHTFUL TO ME.
>> UH... MMM.
>> "DANCE."
>> "AGGRESSIVELY."
(groans)
>> OH, LORD, HAVE MERCY.
>> "DANCE AGGRESSIVELY."
JEEZ, YOU PUT ME
IN A PREDICAMENT.
OKAY.
(laughs nervously)
>> THE NEXT TIME
I'M MAD AT SOMEBODY,
I'M GONNA SAY, "I'M-A KICK YOUR BUTT!""
>> "HIDE."
>> "DIZZILY."
>> (laughs)
>> MAN, MY BRA'S FALLING OFF.
OKAY, THANK YOU.
(laughter)
>> GROOVY.
>> SHE RAN OUT AGGRESSIVELY.
(laughter)
>> (grunts)
>> (laughing)
>> ALL RIGHT, LADIES,
SO THAT WAS A TEST AND A HALF,
WASN'T IT?
SO, EUGENA, COME ON UP.
>> I FELT IT WAS--
IT WASN'T REALLY A SHAKE FOR ME.
I MEAN, YOU COULD'VE
SHIMMIED A BIT.
IT WAS A BIT HALFHEARTED FOR ME.
>> AND EVERY NOW AND THEN
YOU REMINDED ME
OF NAOMI CAMPBELL,
BECAUSE I'VE BEEN
ON PHOTO SHOOTS WITH HER,
AND SHE HAS TO, LIKE, DANCE,
AND THERE WAS A CERTAIN WAY
YOU WERE MOVING YOUR ARMS,
IT KIND OF REMINDED ME OF HER.
BUT, LIKE, A WEAK VERSION OF HER.
YOU GOTTA, LIKE, PUSH STRONGER.
>> BUT IT WAS
DEFINITELY PHOTOGENIC.
I COULD SEE PHOTOGRAPHS.
>> YES.
>> SO FROM MY PERSPECTIVE,
I'M LIKE, BAM, BAM.
>> SO YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
WHERE YOU WERE
UP IN THE HEAVENS.
HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
TO ME, IT LOOKS LIKE
AN ASTRONAUT, NOT A MODEL.
>> YEP.
>> YOU DON'T SEE
ANY OF YOUR LOVELY, GORGEOUS--
>> WE CAN'T SEE
YOUR GORGEOUS FACE.
>> FOR ME,
IT'S--IT'S DEFINITELY THE FACE.
ALWAYS, YOU KNOW, MAKE CONTACT
WITH THAT PHOTOGRAPHER.
AND IT'S EXPRESSING EVERYTHING
THROUGH THE FACE
WHILE BEING AWARE OF YOUR BODY.
>> I DON'T SEE
YOUR MODEL BEAUTY.
I'M NOT SEEING THE MAGIC.
>> JUST ON ANOTHER PLANET.
>> OKAY, UP NEXT IS AMANDA.
ALL RIGHT, AMANDA,
SO FOR YOUR VERB AND ADVERB,
YOU HAD TO SKI SADLY.
I THOUGHT YOU WERE SKIING,
BUT IT DIDN'T LOOK SAD TO ME.
IT LOOKED SCARY.
I LIKE THAT
YOU COMMITTED, THOUGH.
YOU WERE TRYING,
WHEREAS SOME OF THE GIRLS
BEHIND YOU DID NOT TRY.
OKAY, AMANDA,
LET'S SEE YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> LIKE A--THE LETTER "W."
>> IT DOES.
>> YOU LOOK LIKE A BIT LIKE
A DEAD SPIDER IN THIS PICTURE.
YOUR FACE IS PRETTY.
>> MM-HMM.
>> UM, YOU'VE DEFINITELY GOT
GREAT ANGLES,
BUT YOU'VE GOTTA BE CAREFUL
'CAUSE YOUR BODY
IS SO SLIM AND SLENDER
THAT YOU'VE REALLY
GOT TO REALLY WORK WITH IT
TO GIVE US MORE ANGLES.
>> ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU.
UP NEXT--JAEDA.
ALL RIGHT, JAEDA,
SO YOU HAD TO SKIP SENSUALLY.
JAEDA, YOU'RE USUALLY THAT GIRL
THAT GIVES UP IN THIS ROOM,
AND YOU DIDN'T GIVE UP TODAY.
>> BUT WHEN YOU GOT
TO THE "SENSUALLY," YOU JUST...
JUST DIDN'T WANNA
MAKE YOURSELF LOOK DIFFERENT.
>> I FEEL SIMILAR
IN BEING BIGGER,
THAT EVERY CHANCE
THAT YOU CAN USE YOUR BODY--
'CAUSE THAT'S REALLY THE THING
THAT CAN HELP YOU SO MUCH.
IF SOMEONE SAYS, "HEY, DO THIS,"
JUST--JUST DO IT.
>> FOR HER TO SAY
THAT SHE SEES YOU
AS SOMEONE SIMILAR TO HER
IS A REALLY BIG COMPLIMENT.
THAT'S A HUGE COMPLIMENT.
ALL RIGHT, JAEDA,
SO YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
IN A WIND TUNNEL,
AND HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
IT LOOKS LIKE MICHAEL JACKSON.
DOESN'T IT?
LIKE, OLD MICHAEL, KIND OF?
>> GIRL, STOP STARTING RUMORS.
(laughter)
>> YOU SEE WHAT YOU HAVE TO BE
CAREFUL OF IS YOUR CHIN.
>> YEAH.
>> YOU LOOK LIKE YOU HAVE
NO CONTROL OVER YOUR FACE.
>> THE POSE IS--THIS IS ONE
OF MY LEAST FAVORITE POSES.
ALL RIGHT, UP NEXT IS ANCHAL.
>> YOU KNOW, THE TROUBLE IS,
YOU WANT TO BE A MODEL.
WHEN YOU'RE A MODEL,
YOU'RE GIVEN THINGS TO DO,
AND EVERY TIME
YOU'RE GIVEN SOMETHING TO DO,
YOU ALWAYS SEEM
TERRIBLY EMBARRASSED ABOUT IT.
YOU DON'T FEEL HAPPY ABOUT IT.
>> YOU RAN OUT...
>> YOU RAN OUT.
>> LIKE THERE WAS A DOG
CHASING YOU.
YOU RAN OUT AGGRESSIVELY.
WE NEEDED YOU
TO DANCE AGGRESSIVELY,
AND IT WAS THE WEIRDEST EXIT
I'VE SEEN ON "TOP MODEL,"
BESIDES JADE WHEN SHE LEFT.
>> AND IT'S WEIRD
AND DISAPPOINTING BECAUSE
WE'RE HERE BECAUSE
WE BELIEVE IN ALL OF YOU,
AND THEN YOU JUST
THROW SOMETHING AWAY
AND RUN OUT.
IT'S LIKE, WHAT'S THE POINT?
>> AND I THINK THAT THAT'S
REALLY MAYBE ONE
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT LESSONS,
IS YOU SAYING, "I'M HERE.
I'M GONNA BE COMMITTED."
IT'S DECIDING TO BE
A PROFESSIONAL.
>> AND IT'S A LIFE LESSON,
LIKE, IF YOU CONSTANTLY RUN OUT
AND CONSTANTLY SAY THAT
YOU CAN'T DO SOMETHING,
THIS IS PROBABLY
NOT JUST IN MODELING.
IT'S PROBABLY JUST IN GENERAL
WITH YOU IN LIFE.
YOU KNOW, YOU CARRY WHO YOU ARE
INTO THIS COMPETITION.
>> HEAR, HEAR.
>> SO YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT,
AND HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
YOU GOT THE FACE.
>> YES.
>> I'LL SAY, THAT'S--
THAT'S ACTUALLY THE BEST ANGLE
ON THE FACE WE'VE SEEN.
>> JAY SAID THAT
HE HAD SOME STRONG SHOTS,
BUT IN PERSON, HE DOES NOT FEEL
THAT YOU ARE GRACEFUL.
>> I THINK YOU CAN
STILL DO MORE.
IF YOU REALLY HAD GONE FOR IT
HERE, AND I DON'T BELIEVE
YOU DID, YOU COULD'VE DONE
EVEN BETTER THAN THIS.
>> YOU LOOK LIKE MICHAEL
JACKSON, TOO.
>> (laughs)
>> WELL, HERE, SHE DOES.
>> MAYBE HE'S BEEN
LIVING IN A WIND TUNNEL.
>> ALL RIGHT, UP NEXT IS MELROSE.
ALL RIGHT, MELROSE,
SO YOU HAD TO BOX, UH...
>> (laughs)
>> JOYFULLY,
AND WHAT DO YOU THINK
WE MEANT WHEN WE SAID "BOX"?
>> I THOUGHT YOU MEANT, LIKE,
A BOX--LIKE, BE IN A BOX.
>> NO. NO.
>> BUT I DON'T KNOW
THAT IT WAS BOXING
TILL I WALKED OUT.
I'M LIKE, OH, MY GOD.
(laughter)
>> BUT YOU KNOW WHAT WAS FUNNY
IS THAT THIS IS CALLED VOGUING,
AND SO TO MAKE BOXING
FASHIONABLE....
>> YEAH, YEAH.
>> I THOUGHT YOU WERE A GENIUS.
YOU JUST BLEW YOURSELF
RIGHT THERE.
>> AND THE FACT THAT
YOU MADE A COMMITMENT--
AS WRONG AS IT WAS--
IT TURNED INTO SOMETHING RIGHT.
>> SEE, ANCHAL IN THE BACK?
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
>> YES, THE DIFFERENCE.
>> TURN IT INTO SOMETHING RIGHT.
OKAY, YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
IN A WIND TUNNEL,
AND HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> OH, THAT'S BEAUTIFUL.
THAT'S--THAT'S
THE BEST BODY WE'VE HAD.
>> IT'S FANTASTIC.
>> IT IS.
THIS IS ACTUALLY THE FIRST
STELLAR PICTURE WE'VE SEEN.
>> I WAS A LITTLE NERVOUS
AT FIRST WITH ALL OF THE GIRLS,
'CAUSE SO FAR I HAVE NOT LIKED
ALL THE PICTURES
THAT HAVE COME UP,
SO I WAS THINKING THAT
THIS PHOTO SHOOT MIGHT HAVE BEEN
TOO HARD AND IMPOSSIBLE,
AND I'M, LIKE, BEATING MYSELF
UP IN THE HEAD, GOING,
"WHY DID I HAVE THEM DO THIS?"
BUT THEN I SEE THIS AND I GO,
"I HAD YOU GUYS DO IT BECAUSE
A GREAT SHOT IS POSSIBLE."
ALL RIGHT, CARIDEE.
SO, CARIDEE...
>> (laughs)
>> YOU HAD TO DO
A VERB AND AN ADVERB,
AND YOU HAD TO HIDE DIZZILY.
>> YES.
>> WELL...
>> YOU WERE ABSOLUTELY AMAZING.
YOU DID WHAT WE'VE BEEN SAYING.
YOU JUST COMPLETELY COMMITTED.
IT WAS ABSOLUTELY FANTASTIC.
BRILLIANT.
>> THERE WAS A POSE DOWN THERE
WHEN YOU FLIPPED UPSIDE-DOWN
AND YOUR HEAD WAS COCKED.
>> WHAT ABOUT WHEN SHE WAS
SITTING IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE RUNWAY...
>> BRILLIANT.
>> AND SHE'S IN THE MIDDLE
OF ALL OF US, AND YOU JUST
HID BEHIND YOUR FINGERS.
>> AND I WAS JUST LIKE..
>> GREAT.
>> PERFECT. THAT IS SO GENIUS.
>> IT WAS BRILLIANT.
>> YEP, ALL RIGHT. SO YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
IN A WIND TUNNEL,
AND HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> OH, THAT'S PRETTY.
>> YEAH.
>> THAT'S GORGEOUS.
>> THAT'S REALLY NICE.
>> BRILLIANT.
>> YOU KNOW WHY THAT'S AMAZING?
IT'S BECAUSE YOU LOOKED LIKE
YOU WERE PROPELLING FORWARD...
>> YES.
>> LIKE YOU WERE A SUPERHERO
AND GOING FORWARD AS OPPOSED TO,
"I'M IN A WIND TUNNEL AND I'M...
IT'S UNCOMFORTABLE."
IT REALLY LOOKS LIKE
YOU'RE GOING, LIKE,
A HUNDRED MILES AN HOUR.
YOU WERE THE MOST OUT OF CONTROL
ON THE SHOOT, THOUGH.
YOU DIDN'T UNDERSTAND
OR FOLLOW DIRECTIONS FROM JAY,
THE PHOTOGRAPHER
OR THE INSTRUCTORS.
>> (laughs) OH!
>> BUT THAT'S NOT
A GOOD THING, THOUGH, CARIDEE.
SO YOU'VE GOTTA LISTEN.
AND WITH SOMETHING LIKE THIS...
>> UH-HUH.
>> YOU COULD'VE REALLY HURT YOURSELF.
SO IT'S IMPORTANT
TO FOCUS AND LISTEN.
>> YEAH.
>> AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST IS
MICHELLE.
ALL RIGHT, MICHELLE,
SO YOU WERE SUPPOSED
TO SWIM "FRIGHTING-INGLY."
"FRIGHTENINGLY"?
HOW DO YOU SAY THAT?
>> SWIM FRIGHTENINGLY.
>> YEAH, THAT.
>> AND IT WAS REALLY FRIGHTFUL,
I'M AFRAID.
>> YEAH, YOU--
YOU CHICKENED OUT FOR ME.
YOU KIND OF DIDN'T
REALLY GET IT.
>> WHENEVER I SEE
GIRLS LIKE YOU AND ANCHAL,
IT MAKES GO BACK TO CASTING,
AND IT MAKES ME THINK ABOUT
THE GIRL THAT
I DID NOT CHOOSE...
>> MM-HMM.
>> BUT PUT YOU IN HER PLACE.
BECAUSE IT'S, LIKE, THOSE GIRLS
WANNA BE HERE SO BADLY
AND WOULD COMMIT SO HARD,
SO WHEN I SEE YOU
NOT COMMITTING,
IT MAKES ME FEEL LIKE
I WASTED SPACE ALMOST,
AND THAT'S NOT A GOOD FEELING
FOR ME TO HAVE.
>> YEAH, I DON'T WANNA MAKE YOU
FEEL LIKE I'M WASTED SPACE.
>> BUT YOU WERE
THE CHALLENGE WINNER.
(applause)
>> WELL DONE.
>> THEY HAD TO DO
KIND OF A ROLE-PLAY
WHERE STANTON BARRETT IS THIS,
YOU KNOW, BIG NASCAR GUY SAYING,
"BABY, DON'T MODEL.
WHY ARE YOU MODELING?"
AND SHE'S SAYING, "NO!
I'M GONNA PURSUE MY CAREER.
I'M NOT GONNA
LET YOU HOLD ME DOWN."
>> QUITE RIGHT.
>> I HAVE ISSUES.
I CAME UP WITH THAT IDEA
FOR--FOR PERSONAL REASONS.
>> WE ALL KNOW. YEAH, YEAH.
>> WHAT ON EARTH
IS SHE TALKING ABOUT?
>> SO YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
IN A WIND TUNNEL,
AND HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> I LIKE THIS, ACTUALLY.
>> IT'S MICHAEL JACKSON!
>> (laughs)
>> AGAIN! THE GLOVE!
>> DESPITE THE FACT, ACTUALLY,
AS SLIM AS YOU ARE, IN THIS
SHOT
I'M NOT WORRIED BY IT.
HER FACE HAS CAUGHT THE LIGHT
AND IT'S DIFFERENT.
>> JAY SAID THAT YOUR HANDS
LOOKED LIKE A CATCHER'S MITT,
THAT THEY WEREN'T GRACEFUL.
KEEP 'EM SOFT.
ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU, MICHELLE.
SO NOW IT'S TIME
FOR THE JUDGES TO DELIBERATE,
AND WHEN WE CALL YOU BACK,
ONE OF YOU WILL BE
SWEPT AWAY BY THE WIND.
>> ALL RIGHT,
SO NOW IT'S TIME TO DECIDE
WHO IS GOING TO LET THE WIND
BLOW THEM AWAY.
CARIDEE.
>> SHE PHOTOGRAPHS LIKE A
DREAM.
SHE MAKES ME LAUGH EVERY WEEK,
BUT I LOVED HER TODAY.
>> SHE'S WONDERFUL...
BUT SHE'S CRAZY.
>> SO ONE THING
THAT MAKES ME SCARED
IS THE PHOTOGRAPHER'S COMMENT
AND JAY'S COMMENT THAT
SHE WASN'T LISTENING TO ANYONE.
>> (chuckles) OH, HER A.D.D.
>> YOU COULD
REALLY HURT YOURSELF,
AND SHE DIDN'T LISTEN.
>> SHE DOESN'T LISTEN.
>> SO THAT SCARES ME,
THAT SHE'S SO FEARLESS THAT
SHE COULD PROBABLY HURT HERSELF
OR HURT SOMEBODY ELSE
BY JUST BEING SO...
BLAH! OUT THERE.
ANCHAL.
>> THE PHOTOGRAPH IS NOT AS BAD
AS I THOUGHT IT WOULD BE,
BUT, YOU KNOW,
SHE RAN AWAY TODAY,
AND I THINK MAYBE SHE WAS
TRYING TO TELL US SOMETHING.
>> SHE'S GOT A GORGEOUS FACE,
AND SHE'S ONE OF THE FEW GIRLS
THAT'S DELIVERED
A FACE-FORWARD SHOT FOR US.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT?
THIS FOUNDATION IS WHIPPED,
AND I THINK SHE IS, TOO.
>> MELROSE.
>> (laughs)
>> BOX, GIRL!
>> SHE ALWAYS BLOWS ME AWAY.
I THINK SHE PHOTOGRAPHS
AMAZINGLY.
I LOVE HER ATTITUDE.
>> THIS COMPETITION
IS SEPARATING
INTO THE GIRLS THAT COMMIT...
>> YEP.
>> AND THE GIRLS THAT DON'T
COMMIT,
AND MELROSE
IS REALLY GOING THERE.
>> AMANDA.
>> I LOVE A GIRL WHO CAN
MAKE HER BODY LOOK LIKE
A LETTER FROM THE ALPHABET.
THE LETTER "W."
>> IF YOU TURN THE PICTURE UP
THIS WAY AROUND,
IT'S ACTUALLY GENIUS,
AND IT'S AN "M," NOT A "W."
>> (British accent) OH, RIGHT.
OH, BLOODY ME.
>> MICHELLE.
>> I REALLY LIKED
THIS PHOTOGRAPH.
AND THIS IS A HARD SITUATION,
AND I THINK MICHELLE
REALLY LOOKED LIKE
SHE WAS PAYING ATTENTION
TO HER WHOLE BODY.
>> I JUST DON'T KNOW IF
MICHELLE
REALLY WANTS THIS,
AND I SEE HER
KIND OF THROW AWAY A-A TEST,
AND IT JUST MAKES ME GO...
>> SHE REALLY DOESN'T WANT IT.
>> MNH-MNH.
>> JAEDA.
>> I DON'T LIKE
THIS PHOTOGRAPH VERY MUCH,
BUT I THOUGHT
JAEDA'S ATTITUDE TODAY
WAS A LITTLE BIT BETTER.
>> I KNOW SHE WAS VERY EXCITED
TO WORK WITH YOU THIS WEEK,
AND I THINK IT REALLY
PERKED HER UP.
>> EUGENA.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?
SHE STILL HAS TO LEARN
TO TAKE A GREAT PICTURE.
SHE LOOKS LIKE AN INSECT
THAT'S BEING SWATTED IN SPACE.
>> (laughs) SHE DOES.
>> SHE'S SOMETHING VERY
GRACEFUL
AND ELEGANT ABOUT HER.
I THINK SHE JUST
HAS TO PUT IT OUT THERE
JUST A LITTLE BIT MORE.
>> THIS PICTURE OF EUGENA
REPRESENTS HOW SHE IS ALWAYS
WHEN SHE COMES TO JUDGING--
PRETTY LOST IN SPACE.
(laughter)
>> THERE YOU GO.
>> SEVEN YOUNG LADIES
STAND BEFORE ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE SIX PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS.
AND THESE PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE SIX OF YOU THAT WILL
STILL BE IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
CARIDEE.
>> (laughs) OH!
>> CONGRATULATIONS,
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
THE NEXT NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
(laughter)
>> THE BOX.
>> (laughs) THE BOX.
>> MELROSE.
JAEDA.
JAEDA, THIS PICTURE IS CRAPPY,
BUT I CALLED YOUR NAME THIRD
BECAUSE YOU COMMITTED TODAY.
YOU SAID, I'M GONNA LOOK LIKE
AN IDIOT AND FOOLISH,
AND IT'S GONNA BE OKAY.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
THE NEXT NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
AMANDA.
THE NEXT NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
EUGENA.
>> OOH!
OOH!
DOOKIE PICTURE...
>> (laughs)
>> BUT BEAUTIFUL
CHALLENGE TODAY.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU WENT FOR IT.
SHOW ME. WHAT WAS IT?
>> (laughs)
>> SHAKE IT, BABY. SHAKE IT.
I DON'T--SHAKE THE HAIR.
FLIP IT LIKE A WHITE GIRL.
>> (giggles)
>> THERE YA GO!
(laughter)
>> WORK IT OUT!
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU.
(laughter)
>> I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS,
AND THIS PHOTO REPRESENTS
THE GIRL THAT IS
STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
I WILL CALL ONLY ONE NAME.
THE GIRL THAT I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY
RETURN TO THE HOUSE,
PACK YOUR BELONGINGS
AND GO HOME.
ANCHAL, YOU STARTED
THIS COMPETITION...
THIS FACE THAT WAS
SO ABSOLUTELY BEAUTIFUL.
IT WAS ALMOST SCARY,
IT WAS SO BEAUTIFUL.
BUT IF YOU DON'T BELIEVE THAT,
IF YOU DON'T COMMIT YOURSELF
AND SAY, "I MIGHT NOT BE
FEELING
SO BEAUTIFUL RIGHT NOW,
BUT I'M GONNA FAKE IT
UNTIL I MAKE IT,"
IF WE DON'T SEE THAT,
IT MAKES US SAY,
WHY IS SHE HERE?
WHY SHOULD SHE CONTINUE
IN THIS COMPETITION?
MAYBE SHE WANTS IT.
BUT WHEN YOU
REALLY WANT SOMETHING,
YOU SHOW UP AND YOU SHOW UP
HARD
AND YOU SHOW UP STRONG.
AND THEN WE LOOK AT YOU,
MICHELLE--
THE GIRL WITH ALL THIS TALENT,
NATURAL TALENT.
SOME GIRLS JUST HAVE IT.
EVEN IF THEY DON'T NECESSARILY
WANNA MODEL, THEY JUST HAVE IT.
AND I LOOK AT YOU
AND THE JUDGES LOOK AT YOU,
AND WE ALL SAY,
YOU HAVE TO WANT IT.
AND TODAY WITH THE JUDGING
TEST,
THIS ISN'T THE FIRST TIME
WE SAW YOU JUST
THROW SOMETHING AWAY.
>> SO, MICHELLE,
YOU HAVE TO START SHOWING US
THAT YOU WANT THIS.
YOU CAN'T GOOF AND LAUGH
YOUR WAY THROUGH THINGS.
YOU CAN DO THAT
IF YOU'RE DOING A GOOD JOB,
BUT IF YOU'RE MESSING UP,
IT JUST MAKES US SAY,
"WHATEVER,
THERE'S TWO OF 'EM.
JUST--LET'S JUST
GET THE OTHER ONE.
SHE WANTS IT."
YOU DON'T WANT THAT.
>> NO, I DON'T.
>> SHOW US THAT YOU CARE...
>> OKAY.
>> BECAUSE I THINK YOU DO.
>> THANK YOU.
>> CONGRATULATIONS,
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
>> THANK YOU FOR GIVING ME
A GREAT OPPORTUNITY.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
(speaking indistinctly)
>> (crying)
I LOVE YOU.
>> IT'S NOT OVER.
(speaking indistinctly)
>> (speaking indistinctly)
I STILL HATE YOU.
(laughter)
>> I STILL HATE YOU, TOO.
BUT I DON'T. YOU'RE AWESOME.
>> BYE. THANK YOU, EVERYONE.
>> BYE.
>> I'M DISAPPOINTED IN MYSELF
FOR NOT GIVING IT MY ALL
ON THE CHALLENGE OUT THERE.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT?
IN A WAY, I WAS EXPECTING IT.
I'M JUST A LITTLE
SELF-CONSCIOUS,
AND I CAN GET RID OF THAT
AND JUST DO BETTER.
I HONESTLY BELIEVE
THAT GOD HAS SOMETHING ELSE
PLANNED FOR ME,
SO I'M NOT LETTING IT
GET ME DOWN.
OF COURSE, IT HURTS RIGHT NOW
'CAUSE, HEY, LOOK,
I MADE IT SO FAR.
IT'S ME NOT STEPPING OUT
OF MY BOX.
IT'S A LIFE LESSON LEARNED.
♪♪